le confinement ils n'en veulent plus des
centaines de manifestants ont défilé
dans les rues de lima ce week-end contre
le nouveau tour de vis imposé par les
autorités
un confinement de deux semaines a débuté
ce dimanche dans la capitale péruvienne
et dans neuf autres régions du pays
les liaisons aériennes sont également
suspendus avec le brésil et l'europe
dans le but d'endiguer la propagation de
nouveaux variants des mesures que
certains péruvien n'accepte pas le
premier confinement de mars dernier
avait duré plus de 100 jours et laissé 7
millions de personnes au chômage
un scénario que les travailleurs
craignent de revivre je viens pour
défendre celles et ceux qui perdent leur
emploi et ne peuvent par apporter du
pain à la maison je suis une mère
célibataire j'ai cinq enfants et cela me
déséquilibre émotionnellement et
économiquement ce qui se passe c'est que
là le président nous envoie en
quarantaine mais il doit être
intelligent et nous donner un travail
nous voulons travailler nous sommes des
travailleurs indépendants nous avons
deux jeunes enfants à nourrir
ce n'est pas juste je n'ai même pas
assez d'argent pour vivre dix jours ici
mes frères et soeurs vivent la même
chose et nous avons décidé de lutter
contre ces dernières mesures jusqu'à ce
que le gouvernement écoute notre demande
qui est seulement d'être libre de
travailler et si le président francisco
ca gasty après la décision de recombiner
c'est parce que le système ne sentaient
péruvien est au bord du gouffre dans cet
hôpital de la capitale
l'unité de soins intensifs est saturé et
ne peut faire face à l'afflux
grandissant de patients atteints par
cette nouvelle vague de contamination ce
n'est pas un jeu ce n'est pas quelque
chose que l'on prend à la légère
que chacun prenne conscience de ce que
nous vivons maintenant des gens sont en
train de mourir
nous n'avons pas assez de lits
disponibles ni assez de personnel pour
nous aider le personnel aussi est
fatigué qu'à puiser est malade et la
seule façon pour les gens de nous aider
et de rester chez eux
distance physique et de porter le
maillot celui lits sont actuellement
disponibles en soin intensif dans les
hôpitaux de lima et la liste d'attentes
nationale comporte plus de mille
patients dans un état grave
une situation critique alors que le
pérou a déjà enregistré plus de 40 mille
morts jekova 19 depuis le début de la
pandémie